l'obéissance je suis tombé dans la
potion il ya déjà pas mal de temps et
notamment quand j'avais vingt ans
puisque j'étais en 68 dans un lieu qui a
joué un rôle important puisque c'était
la cité universitaire et la faculté de
nanterre et je suis toujours resté
marqué par les idéaux de 68 à la
différence de beaucoup de mes camarades
de l'époque
ce sont des idéaux qu'ils ont continué à
me faire vibrer qui me paraissent même
d'une étonnante actualité
à une époque où précisément à cause des
enjeux écologiques
nous avons impérativement besoin de
changer de mode de production de
consommation de mode de vie eh bien oui
l'alternative au métro boulot dodo
l'alternative à la société de
consommation de compétition me semble
toujours actuelle et puis en même temps
et probablement c'est le bénéfice de
l'âge puisque l'année prochaine je
n'aurai plus 20 ans j'en aurai 70 ce
sera les 50 ans de cette année 68 qui
n'a pas été seulement française parce
que 68
ça a été une fracture mondiale dette en
ouest du nord au sud
rappelons-nous le vietnam la
tchécoslovaquie berkeley et c est en
même temps je fais retour sur mes idéaux
de 68 et je me pose cette question
qu'est ce qui a manqué et qu'est-ce qui
a manqué him on y compris dans ma propre
vie personnelle parce que je me souviens
que à la fois je vivais l'intensité de
cette prise de parole de cette
aspiration à changer de monde a changé
la vie
et puis en même temps il ya quelque
chose qui tournait pas rond ce qui
tournait pas rond c'est que ce qui me
passionnait intérieurement qu'ils
étaient
la question du rapport à l'amour la
question du rapport au bonheur la
question du rapport au sens
et bien quand je me tournais autour de
moi vers mes camarades révolutionnaires
disait mais non ça c'est petit bourgeois
ça tu n'as pas le droit de mettre au
centre ces questions là ce ne sont pas
des questions politiques
ce ne sont pas des questions collectives
et bien d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hui jeudi 6 et je dis d'autant
plus si que si je reprends une grande
question qui est au centre de nos enjeux
de nos résistances de nos débats actuels
surtout après l'irresponsabilité
écologique de donald trump et son refus
d'accepter l'accord de paris qui est ce
fameux problème du dérèglement
climatique
cet enjeux du dérèglement climatique
il est pas simplement du côté du
réchauffement
il n'est pas simplement du côté de sa
version écologique
il a une double face le dérèglement
climatique
et cet autre phase c'est comme le dit
mon ami abdennour bidar la phase de la
glaciation de la glaciation émotionnels
et relationnels
il fait froid dans nos sociétés de
compétition et de consommation et on
comprend bien le lien direct entre ces
deux aspects parce que plus nous sommes
dans la dépression plus nous sommes dans
la solitude et puis nous compensons par
la consommation par la boulimie
d'énergie et donc nous ne pouvons battre
aussi bien personnellement que
collectivement contre la version
écologique du réchauffement climatique
que si nous combattons aussi contre la
glaciation relationnel émotionnel mais à
ce moment là nous avons besoin
effectivement comme le dit pierre rabhi
d'aller vers des sociétés plus frugale
vers des sociétés plus sobre mais encore
faut-il que cette sobriété soit heureuse
sinon nous sommes dans la situation
de proposer un sevrage un toxicomane
s'il n'a pas une espérance positive il
préféra encore rester avec son addiction
alors oui comment cette sobriété
peut-elle être heureuse
cela veut dire que cette question du
bonheur cette question de l'amour
cette question du sens parce que les
trois vont ensemble eh bien il nous faut
les replacer aussi bien au coeur de nos
vies personnelles qu au coeur de nos
projets collectifs
seulement là patatras parce qu'il suffit
de regarder les expressions populaires
à propos du rapport à l'amour à propos
du rapport au bonheur à propos du
rapport au sens pour comprendre qu'il ya
un énorme problème parce
qu'effectivement quelle expression
utilise-t-on quand nous devenons
amoureux quand nous devons non amoureuse
on tombe amoureux
quand une femme va donner la vie elle
tombe enceinte
l'amour est associée à la chute c'était
un rabais hervé bazin qui à propos de la
durée parce qu'à la rigueur on accepte
que l'amour puisse être dans un temps
éphémère mais dès que ça se prolonge
c'est la catastrophe
hervé bazin dans le matrimoine disait
avant de nous marier nous sortions
ensemble
aujourd'hui nous rentrons c'est dire que
la perspective de l'amour n'a rien de
particulièrement séduisant le bonheur
c'est la même chose
le bonheur est associé à l'ennui
rappelons-nous les contes de fées ils
furent heureux et eurent beaucoup
d'enfants
il se passe plus rien fin de l'histoire
c'est vrai sur le plan personnel mais
c'est la même chose sur le plan
collectif les peuples heureux n'ont pas
d'histoire
alors oui si le bonheur est associé à
l'ennui on comprend bien que seul le
malheur est porteur d'intensité et ça
n'est pas par hasard si les médias
dominants surfe en permanence sur ce
sentiment là
donc du côté de l'amour problème du côté
du bonheur problème du côté du sens
c'est pas mieux le sens de la vie est
tellement essentiel aussi bien dans nos
vies personnelles que collectives que
dès qu'on se voit un sens concurrents on
se sent menacé et du même coup le sens
dans l'histoire humaine et très souvent
associé à la guerre les guerres du sens
les guerres de religion les guerres
idéologiques
alors ça peut prendre des proportions
absolument terrible parce que c'est la
cour suprême au nom de cette cause n'ya
même pas les amortisseurs de l'intérêt
du pouvoir de l'argent et c'est au nom
de cette cause
on peut en arriver à tuer le fameux
creed simon de montfort au moment des
guerres de religion en france
tuez les tous et du reconnaîtra les
siens est un cri qui a traversé toutes
les latitudes toutes les périodes c'est
encore au nom de ce cri que des semeurs
de terreur vont porter la mort alors là
aussi si le sens est associée à la
guerre
est ce que cela veut dire que nous
sommes condamnés comme l'évoquait le
philosophe blaise pascal au
divertissement
si effectivement le choix de l'essentiel
le choix de mettre en oeuvre des rêves
nous conduit en réalité au cauchemar
vive l'inessentiel vive le futur le
futile consommons baisons japon mais en
aucun cas ne suivons l'essentiel est
d'ailleurs on nous le dit bien l'enfer
est pavé de bonnes intentions
si nous sommes confrontés à cette
situation hélas est aussi bien une
démarche personnelle que je ressens à
cette occasion que une démarche
collective dans des mouvements sociaux
des mouvements citoyens auxquels je
participe
un en particulier qui s'appelle les
jours heureux
qu'ils repensent flambeau extraordinaire
qui était celui du thème du programme du
conseil national de la résistance qui
était capable de dire au coeur de la
tragédie au coeur de la nuit nord de
l'occupation notre programme nous allons
l'appeler les jours heureux et bien
toutes ces questions rassembler je me
dis effectivement nous ne pouvons
avancer que si nous refusons d'un côté
le divertissement et de toute façon le
divertissement nous est interdite à
cause du défi écologique
nous ne pouvons pas compensée dans la
boulimie de l'énergie dans la boulimie
de la consommation donc la voie du
futile la voie de la course à la
compétition nous sera de plus en plus
interdit donc qu'il nous faut revenir à
l'essentiel et revenir à l'essentiel
c'est dire est ce que nous sommes
vraiment condamner à ce que l'amour soit
du côté de la chute à ce que le bonheur
soit du côté de l'ennui à ce que le sens
soit du côté de la guerre et là je
découvre aussi bien dans ma vie
personnelle que dans mes rapports avec
les autres dans ses mouvements
collectifs que nous ne sommes pas
condamnés nous pouvons nous élever en
amour nous pouvons vivre à la bonne
heure dans l'intensité de la présence à
la vie nous pouvons faire de la
pluralité des traductions de sens une
formidable chance pour l'humanité
oui mais à une condition essentielle
cette condition c'est de sortir de la
logique de contrôle de la logique de
maîtrise pourquoi nous faut-il sortir de
cette logique
prenez la question de l'amour si je veux
maîtriser la personne que j'aime si je
veux la contrôler si je veux en faire ma
possession
eh bien c'est ce que les grecs dans
leurs échelles d'amour at elle apporté
ya la porn eia c'est pas de l'amour
particulièrement hard sur le plan sexuel
c'est le fait de considérer l'autre
comme un objet de possession si l'autre
est objet de ma possession je ne peux
pas découvrir le mystère de l'autre je
suis dans le contrôle c'est la même
chose pour le bonheur si je veux
contrôler la vie ici je veux la maîtrise
et si je veux que le temps de vie soient
en permanence un temps contrôle est
programmée je suis incapable
d'accueillir la vie je suis en
permanence en tension en tension avec un
thé l'attention de la course
attention du stress la tension de la
programmation je ne peux pas être dans
la tension avec un à l'attention de
l'accueil l'attention de la plaine
présence l'attention de la pleine
conscience et qui du même coup est la
source même de la joie de la joie d'être
profonde qui est une alternative comme
le disait le philosophe spinoza aux
passions tristes et c'est la même chose
pour le sens si je veux maîtriser si je
veux imposer mon sens à autrui alors là
oui je bascule soit du côté de la peur
si j'ai peur du sens d'autrui soit du
côté de la domination voire de la guerre
si je veux imposer mon sens inversement
si je considère comme une chance
la pluralité des traditions de sens que
ce soit des traditions de sagesse des
traditions agnostique des traditions at
et des traditions spirituelles des
traditions religieuses
peu importe à condition que ces
traditions soient dans le respect dans
la tolérance et dans le pluralisme parce
que à ce moment là effectivement dans le
vivre ensemble des êtres humains
les questions du sang sont des questions
essentielles
parce que nous savons que nous allons
mourir et parce qu'on sait qu'en vivre
en sachant que nous allons mourir
suppose que nous partagions cette
question fondamentale qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour nous que vivre
et dans ce chemin là comprend outre à ce
moment là que la mort peut être une aide
parce que la mort est précisément ce qui
va nous aider à choisir
l'essentiel dans notre propre vie vie
comme en mourant tu aimerais avoir vécu
dit confucius est dit aussi sénèque
alors à ce moment là oui la pluralité
des traditions de sens est une chance et
bien si tous ces éléments se trouvent
rassemblés
alors je peux retrouver le meilleur de
mon inspiration de 68 le meilleur de mon
inspiration a changé le monde a changé
la vie
mais à condition de dire je ne peux
changer le monde que si je change mon
rapport au monde je ne peux changer la
vie que si je change mon propre rapport
à la vie que si je sors de la maîtrise
du contrôle que si j'accepte
d'accueillir la vie que si j'accepte
d'accueillir le mystère de l'autre dans
l'amour et si tous ces éléments sont
réunis
je peux aussi accéder pleinement non
seulement alain team de la
transformation personnelle mais aussi
aux meilleurs de la transformation
collective ce que le forum social
mondial de porto alegre avait appelé
l'axé pts transformation personnelle et
transformation sociale collective ne
s'opposent plus je peux être pleinement
citoyens de ce peuple de la terre de ce
cette formidable planète qui dès que
nous la voyons vue de l'espace
lauvergeon effect prend tout d'un coup
une image extraordinaire à la fois de
beauté et fragilité et je comprends que
l'enjeu politique principal c'est aussi
celui d'exercer pleinement comme le dit
alexandre jollien mon métier d'homme
et bien si je réunis tous ces éléments
oui la question du bonheur la question
du bien vivre redevient centrale et je
peux dire comme nous le disons au sein
du collectif des jours heureux
choisir d'être heureux est un acte de
résistance politique
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]